ce week-end de la France est qualifié
pour les demi-finales en battent en
Angleterre
[Applaudissements]
présent au Qatar pour assister à ce
match la ministre des Sports Amélie ou
da Castéra a fait elle aussi parler
d'elle et sa tenue était haute en
symbole sur ses photos on la voit porter
un pull bleu aux couleurs de l'équipe de
France mais aussi avec des manches
arc-en-ciel aux couleurs du drapeau LGBT
dans un pays où l'homosexualité est-il
légal et le lendemain elle s'est
expliquée sur son geste au micro de
France Info c'est important d'exprimer
mon engagement en faveur des droits
humains dans leur ensemble et de le
faire sans agressivité à l'égard du
Qatar alors la ministre des Sports porte
un pull aux couleurs LGBT au Qatar
soutenez vous la démarche
[Musique]
voilà alors voilà alors voilà alors
qu'est-ce que tu dis non moi cette image
elle me choque pour deux raisons on peut
pas moi en fait j'aime pas les gens qui
crachent dans la soupe on peut pas se
faire inviter par un pays elle crache
pas aller au Qatar et chier
littéralement sur ce pays en plus de
manière complètement lâche avec un petit
signe comme ça discrètement je trouve ça
dégueulasse et tranquille en loge en
train de manger des petits fours ensuite
la deuxième chose qui me gêne c'est que
c'est clairement deux poids de mesure
quand c'est insupporter qui arbore les
couleurs LGBT il se fait arrêter là
parce que c'est une personne soi-disant
importante ça passe ouais c'est pour moi
c'est lâche c'est pas l'endroit pour le
faire c'est pas le sujet on est dans la
Coupe du Monde c'est une grande fête
populaire et on n'est pas là pour avoir
des revendications et je trouve ça
vraiment gênant moi cette image elle me
gêne cette dame elle crache dans la
soupe c'est pas bien si tu n'aimes pas
ça et ben ne viens pas il coûte la
compétition mais viens pas manger des
des des des du saumon sur des blinis et
mettre un pull qui fait qui fait la pub
oui non mais c'est pas bien de faire ça
de venir horloge et de cracher dans la
soupe moi ça me gêne
elle fait un clin d'œil sans provoquer
un cataclysme diplomatique
justement il y a une sorte de rive
politique elle est la ministre des
Sports il y a l'équipe qui est allé
rester derrière là-bas ou il est reparti
elle est repartie elle est repartie dans
la barrette et donc elle est elle vient
elle vient là en tant que ministre des
Sports supporter l'équipe de France qui
est sur le terrain et en même temps elle
elle véhicule aussi les valeurs de la
France et par ailleurs ça l'a pas
empêché de rencontrer également et de
poser des questions sur la question de
la femme dans le sport au Qatar et elle
a rencontré des athlètes
qatari femme donc voilà elle est dans
son rôle alors qu'est-ce que tu veux
dire toi mamie
faire des courses ensemble
je trouve très bien qu'elle est
rencontrée justement ça je suis d'accord
une ministre n'a pas apporté un t-shirt
militant je suis désolé moi ça me gêne
je suis comme ça
je suis comme
pour un parti politique non c'est toi
c'est pas militant
mais c'est un droit c'est un droit c'est
un droit de l'homme tu comprends ce que
je veux dire là-bas
[Musique]
c'est comme l'égalité des femmes elle
est pas militante
qu'elle est en train de dire je viens
dans ce pays j'accepte la Coupe du monde
mais oui effectivement je me lève sur le
fait que chez vous
les spectateurs s'il vous plaît
comprenez vous la démarche non à 67%
Daniel et Guillaume que ça veut dire que
enfin non mais c'est la ministre
peut-être que pour la démarche de la
ministre pas voilà c'est c'est voilà
c'est que c'est voilà après il y en a
d'autres aussi monsieur
les vidéos normales moi j'ai bossé hein
peut-être alors d'accord si c'est si
être contre ce t-shirt salé on est 68 %
d'homophones
parler tous les deux je vous avais
jamais je vous amènerai tous les deux tu
viendras on sera dans la voiture je vous
mettrai l'arrière non mais tu sais ce
qui me rend fou tu sais ce qui me rend
fou j'aurais fini avec ça ce qui me rend
fou c'est que à part moi bien non ce qui
me rend fou c'est que aujourd'hui
racisme tout le monde s'élève contre ça
et c'est normal décrit de singe sur un
dans un match de foot on crie tous à ça
et c'est normal la violence faite aux
femmes on crie tous à ça et c'est normal
l'homophobie c'est une question de
culture mais là en revanche
et j'aimerais juste pardon pour mettre
les trois au même niveau c'est aussi
grave de frapper un gars que de frapper
un noir que le racisme ou que de frapper
une femme et quand j'entends Gilles
quand j'entends Guillaume on est encore
un cran non mais tu vois ce que je veux
dire le combat est aussi important il y
a pas